this episode of congratulations is
brought to you by blue apron blue apron
is teaming up with best-selling cookbook
author Chrissy Teigen who is the
sweetest girl in the world to bring you
some of her favorite recipes to make at
home get ready for six weeks of wildly
fun flavorful cooking featuring recipes
like garlic and soy glazed shrimp with
charred broccoli and hot green pepper
sauce and sesame chicken noodles with
bok choy did we mention you don't have
to step foot in the grocery store no we
didn't but we just did so you don't have
to I'll talk about this more later in
the show so check out this week's menu
and get your first three meals free at
blue apron calm / Congrats that's blue
apron calm / Congrats get your first
three meals free blue apron a better way
to cook episodes also brought to you by
the cash app babies and all of us babies
use the cash app which is why it's the
number one finance app in the App Store
and now the cash card is more powerful
than ever with cash apps latest feature
cash boost download the cash app get
your free cash card and select your
boost save money when you swipe on stuff
like coffee Chipotle Shake Shack and
more download the free cash app for iOS
or Android now it's a New Jersey glass
that my mommy gave my mommy made gosh
probably I don't know how it went up in
my cupboard but definitely my mom
and it's a New Jersey glass and every
time and all my mom does is get me New
Jersey stuff because we're from New
Jersey and oh my aunt does is get me
Batman stuff because one one time when I
was seven I said it like that man and we
like it it's how you show love in my
family gifts
some people show love differently and
some people are gift givers and some
people there lot of language is [ __ ]
and some people's love language is
touching and aka [ __ ] I don't know
what that whole love language [ __ ]
is but people are like what's your love
language every now and then some new
[ __ ] will come out and everybody'll be
all about it and then they'll forget
about it like the secret member when
that was big everyone was manifesting
their destiny and then everyone stopped
manifesting their destiny and everything
is always the same no matter what if you
manifest your destiny or not manifest
your destiny remember that emember so
you can wake up and put a vision board
on the [ __ ] ceiling and wake up and
the first thing you see is Donuts and
then you can go get donuts did you
manifest your destiny did the [ __ ]
thing on the ceiling have anything to do
with that did the secret have anything
to do with that or did your brain and
did your legs walk into the donut store
have mostly what to do with that you
want donuts get donuts it's not the
secret um guess what guys I was in oh I
was in ok so I was in Tulsa I was in
Midwest City those of you don't know
where that is
is in Oklahoma and then I was also in
Dallas now I've been to Dallas plenty of
times love Dallas like performance
performing there at the crowds were
always as they would say lit AF ok now
before I get into that I had an early
flight the other day from Dallas or from
Midwest City which is Oklahoma City was
where the airport was Oklahoma City to
Dallas now when I got there I realized
the drive is three hours now I told my
travel agents of course if it's three
hour drive versus a [ __ ] 40-minute
flight take the drive because by the
time you get to the airport and do all
the [ __ ] it still takes just as long or
even longer now they booked flight yeah
am I upset yeah am I gonna say something
to him now yesterday I was like I gotta
say some dumb now today I woke up a
little less heated am I gonna say
something ultimately no it's gonna
happen again yes am I going to get
equally as met yes
not doing anything about it yes okay now
that's just how it works you get mad you
say you're gonna do something and then
you don't and that's what this country
is based on man you get mad you get
heated you forget about it you don't
change a goddamn thing the micro to
macro babies so I did that and then I
got home yesterday and then [ __ ] fell
asleep at 11 o'clock like I'm eight
number 38 year old man now I'm a comic I
stay up late fell asleep at 11:30 at
night like I do like I do poopy in my
pants and then I woke up at [ __ ]
10:00
dude you know what that [ __ ] you know
what that makes you feel like you wake
up at 10 10 hours of sleep dude ten
hours of [ __ ] sleep no wrong one oh
it's labeled wrong okay it's labeled
wrong one fire I wanted back in black
and I hit the W and it [ __ ] hit made
me hit him up and we're angry it's all
good but we're angry now we went 0 to 60
in in the anger category what are we a
[ __ ] are we a on 911 Turbo are we a
[ __ ] cherry red 911 Turbo going from
0-60 on that anger freeway because of
one fire yes we are are we gonna let
that disrupt the the show were not Anna
did it yeah but are we back on track
yeah so whatever dude I got 10 hours of
sleep what I'm trying to say is I got
more sleep than you and I'm bragging
about it I'm [ __ ] bragging about it I
got more sleep than you you got 5 hours
of sleep cuz it's a Monday you couldn't
fall asleep on your Sunday night cuz the
weekend I got them you know you're on
the weekend [ __ ] you got nothing you
didn't get it and I did and I got 10
hours of sleep and that makes me feel
[ __ ] amazing dude
I love 10 hours of sleep people
you know how how about some people who
are like well I had a buddy once I'd be
like you know you should get four hours
of sleep for hours getting four hours of
sleep is better than getting six hours
of sleep see ya dude people like that
they love to be different man
you don't yeah why cuz the sleep cycles
and your sleep cycles for hours there's
a full sleep cycle you see for hours and
you see before eyes you get to full
sleep cycles in get six hours you've
Minter up the sleeps like wake up you're
groggy all day oh really
well I got something ahead no no more
sleep better than less sleep unless of
course you're getting [ __ ] 90 hours
of sleep at once then you dead fan only
non-lethal BAM praying I I was in Tulsa
now I have to say I was a little bit
excited to go to Oklahoma because I've
never been there before and I wanted to
see it now I went to Tulsa first did a
show the shows were all great
Tulsa Midwest City Dallas great shows I
had a great time okay
Tulsa was fine cool little area I guess
it's got a little bit of a like I say I
like to say it's got a little bit of a
pulse to it and a vibe alright then I
went to Midwest City now when I got to
Midwest City the first thing I saw was
Robin and I mean Robin as in Robin and
Batman and he was walking with another
[ __ ] woman that was dressed up in pink
pigtails and had on like some weird
Japanese skirt now all of a sudden I
thought I stepped into a [ __ ] weirdo
zone what we call the weirdo zone okay
and we saw we saw Robin I saw Robin and
I was like hey what the [ __ ] going on
then I saw more people dressed in
costume
saw Deadpool saw two other characters
never seen before in my life guy had a
[ __ ] blue face see ya and I realized
we were in something called the Sooner
fest and I was like what the [ __ ] of
the sooner fest now I still don't know I
walked around there was a convention
there everyone would people were signing
autographs and creating art it was like
some animate versus
I wasn't the Sooner fan fest' that would
be football on fire it will be sooner
fast and it was there were people
dressed up as characters I had never
seen before there was somebody dressed
up as Deadpool though and [ __ ] like that
he had on a vest it looked like Deadpool
the waiter and or Deadpool the valet and
I let me fight crime or get your car so
so I went to go get by the way I'm live
on my app here you can get the first ten
minutes of the [ __ ] show always live
on my app if your subscriber to my app
just download my app go to the Chris
D'Elia store you can do that and get the
podcast before anybody gets it yeah so
is that sooner fest and saw a bunch of
let's see them let's see man I don't
wanna offend anybody but extreme dorks
dressing up now it's cool that they have
a [ __ ] thing that they can do and be
happy about and I'm not bagging on that
but you know come on and so they were
all dressed up about this don't ever
dress up as anything but yourself unless
you're [ __ ] eleven there you go don't
you're [ __ ] eleven diddle in then so
okay so I I was there and I don't there
was there was fat flash the flat the
flash that looked like he kind of
[ __ ] retired a few years ago and was
like I hate it going quick actually
that's really funny dude hey he was so
he was really big and overweight hey
don't dress up as the flash because
you're not doing cardio I don't get um
actually I don't get what it is about
you know a part of me was like why do
why is it always overweight people that
do cosplay unless you're a [ __ ] chick
with fake boobs but it's not that it's
that those costumes look so unflattering
if I put that on I look like a [ __ ]
schlub I'd look like a dad you know
immediately I'd have dad Bob dad bod if
I put on a Superman suit so you know and
I'm trying to friend I told you my
[ __ ] sweat beads are dripping down to
double black diamond
AB lat courses I told you but I saw them
I saw s so many dorks and it's all good
I'm a dork too in my own way so I'm not
trying to say I'm better than you
but I was taking pictures of those guys
and let me tell you besides that okay
walked around a little bit Midwest City
now I've been flirtin with not saying
this people have been saying don't go
don't say stuff about Midwest City if
you're like we know our city sucks but
please go easy on us on the podcast got
those tweets now I want to tell you
something and I want to and I want to
tell you something now this is a comedy
podcast so I want you to keep that in
mind but I also want you to know there's
a little bit to truth the comedy okay
now when I tell you this it's funny
however there's absolutely a little bit
goddamn truth to it I've been to a lot
of different places in this world I will
say country though right
it's not like I'm well-traveled I
haven't been a [ __ ] Prague now I've
been to a lot of places in America hands
down hands down
Midwest City ugliest people I've ever
seen in my goddamn life of these people
ever seen in my goddamn life now that's
fine I understand being a you know
you're born with the face you're born
with but how about this go for a jog
that's cool however do a jumping jack I
mean these people were Oh beasts dude
hey put down the burger
hey you know what go for a hike do
something besides sit dude I saw a lady
sit in the lobby I I kept coming up and
down in the elevator because every place
was more depressing the last my room was
depressing and also the lobby was
depressing and outside was depressing so
I kept switching because I didn't wanna
be that if I wanna be a different new
depressed I kept going to the lobby I
saw a lady melting into the couch for
hours with blue hair she was bald on top
and she looked dude she was big man she
looked
she was [ __ ] but Jesus Christ she was
big and then I heard this this was the
pinnacle I heard somebody say I don't
wanna walk and then I saw her round the
corner she was 200 pounds and 17 and she
was saying she'd want to walk to the
elevator which takes you somewhere up
[ __ ] that walk up the flights and I know
I'm being harsh but also how about this
you're gonna die you know now it's a
comedy podcast but you're gonna die I
don't know what I stepped into dude and
I know this is a hacky joke right here
but it was the Star Trek [ __ ] party
scene dude I walked into and they were
dressed up like superheroes Oh Dan
that's gonna sound ill in your speakers
I want to know what the ugliest cities
are you guys got to tweet me and show me
some analytics what the ugliest cities
are and I know it's all based on yeah
but who are they on the inside but the
truth is I just got sad like I work I
work out hard work out a little bit I
don't know or don't but you're gonna die
and then it's very selfish to be that
big cuz you're gonna die and then your
family's gonna be sad do step aerobics
head um alright some guy in the app said
Billings Montana well I'll never go
there um so yeah do it
that was that was crazy it was it was
wild there and so I did the show there
the show was great people at my show
were not exactly the ugliest but you
know
so I I don't know I hurt my buddy got my
buddy got let go he got fired and I was
thinking about this I was thinking about
how my buddy got fired and he
immediately said well like we were
talking about and he was like do his
best thing that ever happen to me and
that's one of the top 5 funniest things
that anybody could ever do is react to
getting fired like saying it's the best
thing that ever Avenue and I guarantee I
bet if you took a percentage of how many
people say that after they get fired
I better be like 12 that's too high it's
too high
I better be 12 and here's the other
thing it's also a sane secure and it
says sad David Brent because here's the
other thing do they always stay away too
quickly right like it's one thing I was
what listening to a TED talk the other
day and this lady who they called the
machine she was Australian and she was
going to the Olympics that she was
killing it and she was [ __ ] better
than anybody doing anything Jeanine the
machine or some [ __ ] her name was anyway
huge was taking a bike ride got creamed
by a [ __ ] truck okay then got
paralyzed then became she was like well
Who am I what my identity was in the
Olympic my debt my identity was becoming
the [ __ ] Olympian athlete and my
identity was my body and I realized my
identity was not my body and should be
I'm a pilot dude she was paralyzed
became a pilot and became like the
[ __ ] the the first female aviation
president of some [ __ ] I mean so
ruining it but you know became a really
important person in aviation and and
flew and by the way you need do you need
to hit the pedals when you fly but she
was like [ __ ] that I'm using my hands
okay she did that and became a [ __ ]
she and the podcast and the TED Talks
podcast they were like hey also she's a
she's still the machine she's just a
machine in a different way and it was
very touching and I teared up and it was
amazing okay but and it turned out she
said and she said at the end of this
podcast was like getting hit by the
truck was the best thing that ever
happened to me now fine that's cool but
these people are getting fired saying
that [ __ ] it's like they might as well
be saying
like they go like you're fired and then
they go yes it's not the best thing that
happened to you right away dude be sad
be sad you got fired these people love
to be it's so defensive
they love to just get like - like I'll
[ __ ] oh my girlfriend left me oh man
I'm so sorry no you know what honestly
is the best thing that ever happened to
me why well because you know what we
obviously weren't right if she thought
we weren't right then we weren't right I
don't wanna have to convince her we to
cry nope best thing never happened
honestly they're tears of joy they're
tears of joy
you broke hey man I break up with you ah
yes hey man I cheated on you yes mm-hmm
oh dude you cheated on me are you
[ __ ] kidding me
you [ __ ] cheated on me dude you got
fired
hey man we'll have to bring in here look
look man I know it's near Christmas time
and you need to get a bunch of gifts for
your family but sorry you're fired I'm
fired yeah well
[Music]
it's a best thing that ever happened to
me right away immediately I make no
money and I have to buy gifts for all my
family and I'm Mormon I have eight kids
yes it can be the best thing that ever
happened you because now you could go
into a new venture and become a [ __ ]
swimmer or become a space pilot or be a
[ __ ] paraplegic aviation leader okay
but you can't do it today be sad that
you got fired and then have it be the
best thing you never happen to you I
don't like when people [ __ ] with it's
like when people when someone's mad and
and you're like oh I'm sorry I hurt your
feelings or like nah it doesn't get hurt
my feelings I'm just pissed oh really
well that's what that is you hidin don't
hide B purse it's free current you can
act however you want to but can't be
purse alright cuz otherwise and I hate
to say this and I don't say this a lot
but side the [ __ ] Nora
god I hate saying this but I see you
later right umm yeah so but that TED
talk was crazy man it is wild imagine
taking I imagine this a lot like cuz I
always think about like dude comedies my
life I love it and I identify identifies
a comedian you know and that's my gender
I identify as a comedian on the gender
scale on the gender spectrum there's a
man and then there's woman and then in
the middle there somewhere comedian and
if they have a cockerel [ __ ] whatever
that is that's what I have but you know
these sports players these [ __ ]
athletes these football players that
they have to like they get hit and then
they can't play anymore dude I think
about that sometimes I mean these
football players have to retire at 33
you know what I mean
dude I'm 38 man I just it's like that
would be a life ruiner man jump off a
building hit a car alarm goes off well
that's it I mean dude if I it's like
you know I don't mean to be dramatic but
if you take something away from somebody
that's what they live for
Jesus man rough but you got to keep
going I guess I don't know I guess you
got to keep going you're not supposed to
kill yourself right how about the guy
that tweeted hey if you kill yourself
you don't go to heaven so you shouldn't
do that it's a sin right after [ __ ]
Anthony Bourdain got it killed himself
it's like hey bro
first of all give it time second of all
believe in whatever you want to believe
in but third of all don't [ __ ] talk
[ __ ] about the dude that just had a
problem [ __ ] these religious people
men look religion is cool man
like [ __ ] if it makes you happy and
it makes you feel better great right but
don't go to war over it hey don't go to
war to it he said as he sipped his
homemade iced americano in his New
Jersey cup and he meant it
you could tell behind his eyes it's just
[ __ ] this world is Sosa [ __ ] and
it's so [ __ ] what do you call it
it's insecure everybody's so insecure
dude when when Kanye made the rap song
we're all insecure I'm just the first to
admit it now you're not the first to rap
about it no a little bit your first big
guy to rap about it maybe but it's like
s insecure if I was rap I want to make a
song called sin secure and and then in
the chorus it's good hey hey you're
fired
yes that's how it starts you're fired
yes I've been noticing online a lot and
[ __ ] like that a lot of celebrities
can't wait to share news dude this [ __ ]
drives me nuts it's not news if you
can't share it news is always shareable
if it can't share it it's not news yet
therefore shut the [ __ ] up till it's
news and shareable therefore these
[ __ ] celebrities some of these
celebrities that have [ __ ] dick all
going on they might as well just be
sitting at a [ __ ] country
Club cuz they've got time they might as
well be wearing a vest
with a bunch of pockets on it cuz
they're on a hike cuz they got no they
love saying can't wait to share this
exciting news what would you do get a
dog Oh what is it a career what are you
gonna do what the [ __ ]
can't wait got so many exciting things
to share share them then share them then
what can you not tell us dude and you
know the celebrity summer you probably
see it happen all the time celebrities
on Instagram can't wait to share all the
exciting things for the future it is the
future now shehram it's four seconds
later if it's news share it what news
outlet didn't share news if anything
people share [ __ ] way too soon I can't
say why what's gonna happen you're gonna
lose your deal no what do you [ __ ]
work for a Marvel no what are gonna be a
[ __ ] you know well you got an article
written about you who the [ __ ] cares
that's not no Gizzi [ __ ] it's not a dude
just do your life stop bragging you
deserve a fart noise in your face can't
wait to share all this exciting news I
just can't talk about it yet yeah you
can what are you [ __ ] the next
spider-man what dude every every script
I get now to to read it's got my name
plastered all over it because they're
like they want to know if it gets leaked
out that it was made dude nobody cares
about your [ __ ] goddamn romantic
comedy who gives a [ __ ] oh yeah they
don't they're really secretive with the
sides who gives a [ __ ] what is it
[ __ ] Star Wars it's not it's some
[ __ ] romantic comedy with like I
don't know somebody in it I don't want
to think of [ __ ]
Oh canvas music um yeah I'm gonna read
these [ __ ] ads I think here dude um
I'm disrespectful you know that you know
I'm a disrespectful dude and I'm gonna
[ __ ] order food right now and it
might even get here before the [ __ ]
podcast ends and I'll end it how about
that dude that's a [ __ ] gangster I am
I'll end it cuz the food's here dude oh
you think I give a [ __ ] you're all on
board too hey it was an international
log or it was national log cabin day
yesterday did you guys know that you
know how I hate days yesterday was
national log cabin day
hey well besides the fact that I know
it's our day I mean really bro you're
gonna have a [ __ ] national log cabin
day who the thoughtwhat grizzly
[ __ ] decided to have that what
flannel-wearing axe [ __ ] wielding
wood chopper [ __ ] him
decided to petition for national log
cabin day imagine celebrating that well
we are you know we are cuz we're all
true we're all real babies that's what
we are we're babies some of us are
newborns and some of us are [ __ ] a
year and a half old but we're all babies
I don't care til well ten years old
we're babies were thirty and thirty
years we're all babies but that's that's
the truth it was national log cabin days
day um hey guys me undies you've
definitely heard me talk about me undies
you know the fun comfy undies that feel
as good as they look to those of you
that haven't tried them yet listen up
dude you can get incredible underwear
sent to your door with me undies meaning
no more hunting around for the perfect
pair at a crowded store and eventually
settling for good enough these are great
I wear them all the time I have
different patterns I put them on no
matter how I feel I got ones with
bananas on them I got ones with peace
signs on them and I got ones with pandas
on them and I also have regular you know
purple pink black purple you know I
already said that grey different
just regular standard ones and they all
feel amazing they're the best underwear
I've ever put on my body they're sure
you'll love your first pair and if
you're not happy they'll do whatever
they can to get you into the right pair
and if they can't keep them and they'll
refund you so it's risk free try the
best underwear ever you're still not
sure well my undies has a deal for my
listeners first-time purchasers get 20%
off their first pair of me undies and
free shipping that's 20% off plus free
shipping and a guarantee that you and
your me undies will be very happy
together
get your butt over to me undies calm and
treat yourself to get your 20% off your
first pair free shipping and a hundred
percent satisfaction guarantee go to my
undies comm slash Congrats that's my
undies com / Congrats blue apron I love
it if you've had it you'll love it and
if you hadn't had it what the heck you
doing blue apron delivers fresh
pre-portioned ingredients step-by-step
recipes right to your door that can be
cooked in under 45 minutes the menu
changes every week based on what's in
season and is designed by blue aprons
in-house culinary team 12 new recipes
each week and customers can pick two
three or four recipes based on what best
fits your schedule I love blue apron
because it's non-gmo ingredients and
meat with no added hormones when you go
to a restaurant you don't know what
you're getting you know they're injected
with all sorts of stuff blue apron
doesn't do that and it also all tastes
good I haven't had a bad meal and I've
had a ton of these blue apron meals
Chrissy Teigen is partnering up with
them and she's got some recipes coming
up upcoming meals Chrissy Teigen --zz
garlic and soy glazed shrimp with
charred broccoli and hot green pepper
sauce sauce Chrissy Teigan sesame
chicken noodles so check out this week's
menu and get your first three meals free
at blue apron calm / Congrats that's
blue apron calm / congrats to get your
first three meals free blue apron a
better way to cook dude guess what shirt
I'm wearing I'm wearing the orange shirt
that the girl said was pink am i
incorrigible everyone always asks can I
see a picture that shirt if you want to
look at the video podcast this is the
orange shirt and I try to wear different
shirts on the podcast because there's
really nothing to distinguish the
thumbnails on which episode is what and
where I said what's like I've wore the
camouflage shirt like twice
and so now people don't know what's what
but that's it dude you got to watch
every episode that's the thing you got
to watch every episode if you're a true
baby if not you're not a true baby and
that's okay you can be a baby's freak
hunch but be a real baby man
you know what the new pizza humor is nap
humor I tweeted about this the other day
you're not interesting cuz you think
it's fun to take naps and put it online
everyone likes naps you know what we
need naps you know why
naps you know what they are sleeping
needs sleeping now I think it's [ __ ]
we have to sleep eight hours a day or
otherwise we're a zombie how about the
fact that if I get dude if I get four
hours of sleep I'm [ __ ] if I get five
hours of sleep I'm [ __ ] five and a
half I'm [ __ ] six doable
seven good eight great nine we takin
over if I get less than five and a half
hours sleep I'm straight-up [ __ ] I am
I'm [ __ ] dude that's not fair god
that's not fair Jesus Christ that sucks
we have to charge for so long when my
iPhone has a power charger that charges
in like 40 minutes and then I can use it
all day that's [ __ ] dude we need to
be more like Apple that sucks donkey
balls
and you know I hate saying it but it
sucks donkey balls a long time my
brother and I were we we were in LA
cañada where we grew up
and after New Jersey and we left so hard
we ran into this guy who was like a
saqqaq and he was a dad he was a dad in
LA cañada and he was like hey guys how's
it going and I had already graduated
high school and so I had my brother I
think and my cousin was in high school
he was on the football team and we was
like his name's Nick
and he was a
my cousin and he was like hey yeah I'm
so so doing football you know football
my sons in football cool like that and
it was like oh yeah and I said how's
Nick doing he says he said it's great
yeah he's good and he changed it like he
went like oh yeah it's great you know
he's good and now the joke we always
bring up my brother and I was said we
say like how's Nick doing a foot boy he
says oh it's great oh you know he sucks
balls he sucks balls we don't we changed
it to suck balls sucks balls they say uh
how is he at football that's what's
balls and sell my brother and I had a
sex ball so any time we say like oh how
was he in the movie uh it was great
balls it's a drastic so much of a change
yeah but yeah but you need to sleep and
if you don't sleep your [ __ ] I'm [ __ ]
dude and I'm one people to say I don't
need a lot of sleep like I got a buddy
Brent Morin he gets four hours of sleep
at night and he's like yeah I don't know
I don't sleep that well but it's all
good and I'm never tired but you look
like a bloody eye I mean he always looks
tired as [ __ ] go to bed Brent dude he
would show up and undateable and she he
would show up I mean guys a handsome guy
but he would show up he always looked
out of work you know that's how you look
when you don't get enough sleep
you look [ __ ] out of work and and he
had a job he had a high paying job we
were [ __ ] actors on on the show I
mean you're an actor you're [ __ ]
making money right on a series it's the
sideways bragging you know cuz I was on
the show too but I'm not I'm just saying
and obviously and I mean more money than
him but it's all good dude it's all good
you know this is first real job and I've
been in the band but he got for us a
sleepover night woke up bloodshot eyes
looked like an out-of-work guy dude
there isn't a more sound of work looking
guy than Brent Morin handsome guy got
swag and he's sexy in his own right
but uh [ __ ] so funny dude my best
friend so don't shut the [ __ ] up if
you're trying to be like oh he's talking
[ __ ] about you on the podcast and I know
he's listening cuz he listens to [ __ ]
all the episodes did the guys great and
shout-out to his [ __ ] parents that
have 46 that had it yesterday a 46 and a
year anniversary for their further
that's great man killing at 46 imagine
being made for 46 years
imagine being alive for 46 years
you know Wow god bless him his parents
are the [ __ ] man I love when people have
good parents it makes me so happy you
know what else I hate I hate when people
break up I hate it it makes me sad I
don't know I'm this [ __ ] I don't give
a [ __ ] kind of type guy but I really do
do it secretly there's a hard man how
about when people say like to you like I
know you're a good person sometimes it's
just hard to see and you're like you
don't even forget anomie but his parents
are great man I think it's cuz I love my
parents so much and then when I see
people have great parents it makes me so
extra happy cuz I know that they're
gonna shape up to be a all they're gonna
shape up to be a okay anyway
[Music]
well this hand naps you need naps dude
I'm [ __ ] if I get four hours of sleep
on my zombie I can't work out I can't
concentrate I can't if I meet people
people are like what's up with that
[ __ ] guy that's how I am but yeah I
know
of it I love sleeping it's sucks we have
to sleep for so long right we kind of
figured something out
like we got to do some sort of like long
if we were like bears that would be even
better if we just hibernate for like two
months and then don't have to sleep for
ten months that would be the [ __ ] right
in some dystopian there's some [ __ ]
stupid movie with John Cusack that
they're making right now about that by
the way probably some dystopian like in
the future they don't sleep every day
they sleep for two months and for ten
they fight and then it's so cold it's
always so cold in dystopian futuristic
movies or super hot and everyone wears
either black or brown what happened to
colors in movies about the future what's
that all about even if it takes place in
like a I guess the fifth element but
unless has aliens in it to it if it's
just about the human race in the future
nobody's wearing yellow or pink there's
no pink every movie is like the world
exploded and they rebuilt nothing from
the ashes
until the phoenix rose and now we have a
society on fish people and there's no
pink and yellow for sure and no great
brain the only green they have is moss
green and they have some red if it's
dark like maroon and grey and black
always and or white sometimes but that's
it
this summer john cusack
Ellen Page
that lady who's all the way the old lady
was always enough judi dench bro or if
we couldn't get her ellen barkin in a
sleepless world bro
will you just hibernate in white pods
with clear glass on the front of it all
together huh dude like [ __ ] wrong
well you have to actually give me enough
time because of the prom no that's not
fair let me describe the world before
you put in the next instrument wrong um
yeah dude I can't I can't [ __ ] why is
this thing [ __ ] blinking as a [ __ ]
ruin you know not recording for sure it
has a t-38 it's all good it's it blinks
every now and then it's fine it's got
time it goes time get nervous whenever I
record I always get nervous I'm not
recording
oh [ __ ] imagine if we did a whole
episode and didn't record it it's my
biggest fear yeah cuz then we'd have to
do it again and I would be so sweaty you
know what the good news is I'd do it
naked
so I'd do it [ __ ] straight-up naked
or is there video on that is there well
audio on that I would just release it
then [ __ ] all video whatever I don't
give a [ __ ] dude you know what it's not
gonna happen
how about that Oh some biggest fear he
had a podcast 74 weeks in a row wrong
all recorded on audio bro 82 degrees in
a small room Brahm sweat would bead from
his [ __ ] tit chest and [ __ ]
cascade over his black diamond beautiful
after all
one episode didn't record no it didn't
record all do it did I ever do that it's
beautiful thing my brother and I now
have another inside joke about it was
called a Goliath awaits there's this
movie called Goliath awaits and it's a
head the whole movie is hey if you watch
the movie you can't [ __ ] not go like
this every [ __ ] three minutes hey it
was with a family friend we used to have
this family friend Mark Harmon he's an N
CSI CSC is NCS n-double-a-cp whatever
the [ __ ] that show is called I like how
they made the CSI show and then they
were like yo just put an N in front of
it and we'll make 40 of them different
[ __ ] factions don't give a [ __ ]
anyway show's been on for seven hundred
and sixty-five years and Goliath waits
they made the [ __ ] a movie and
[ __ ] Mark Harmon was like 34 in it or
some [ __ ] and it was about an
underground society and a sink ships and
it goes leagues under the sea and a
society is made and the water never got
into the ship somehow and there's air
down there somehow no and a lady was
born and she's never seen the light of
day long
[Music]
and of course all she wanted to ever do
was see the Sun and she talks about it
in a monologue probably I don't remember
but it definitely happened because
that's what would happen in that movie
Goliath awaits and they ate anyway
[ __ ] somehow Mark Harmon gets trapped
down there and he's like oh yeah he
tells her about the Sun I think and
she's like I'd like to see it and then
at the end of the [ __ ] movie of
course there's like a little dinghy that
they get up on and like four of them get
up and rise into the one fire his
[ __ ] thing went up in unless that
would have been good with the [ __ ] me
talking about the movie actually what
I'm kind of a [ __ ] ass ring do you have
would you just win trivia and so we've
goliath awaits so so they get in this
[ __ ] pod and it goes all the way up
and it goes out into the top of the
ocean and it shows and it opens up
school you know and and she sees the Sun
for the first time ever and this is how
the movie ends and what this was I think
this was the birth of ah because we were
kids and she sees the Sun and it shows
the Sun and then she says it's beautiful
and it ends s abruptly and the the music
starts and it goes dong like you know
how that's there would be you know how
many movies ended like that in like
before 1990 it would be like we finally
found it or I guess the trail led here
or finally we've got all the riches and
then we go don't know or whatever but it
was always story a lot of westerns did
that like it would be like well the town
safe again dog not to be confused with
wrong which is every movie preview now
every single movie preview now
so so she sees the Sun and she goes
it's beautiful tall and it would go it's
beautiful down and we [ __ ] ran with
that boy you never know what's gonna
become such a thing such an inside joke
but holy [ __ ] man it's beautiful we do
that all the time
it's so funny man you got to see the end
of this movie somebody find it and tweet
me it's probably not lick in my head
it's it's probably literally nothing
like that you're probably watching you
be like it's not that bad Chris but over
the years it's literally it's beautiful
and now it even happens before I bet
like as its its we've made it so quick
that now happens 30 minutes in the movie
in the movie ends boom
the movie was hit so bad so bad bad
movies are better than good movies dude
I don't give a [ __ ] what you say bad
bettors bad betters hmm bad movies are
better than good movies because good
movies suck dude because they're trying
so hard to make you cry or feel some
[ __ ] there are exceptions but these
[ __ ] good movies got a go bro these
move good movies gotta go get out of
here with your good movie [ __ ] oh
you won an award make a movie called
[ __ ] what's that the hunter's blood
there you go
I'll watch that in the theater what you
see some cool hearing things here we go
guys ad break keepsake is a new thing I
want I want to talk about with you guys
and it's very cool I've started doing
this we all have great photos on our
phone remember we took those do you
remember where to find them no because
you got seven hundred million thousand
photos in your phone and you don't know
where that good picture is birthdays
graduations weddings I mean you're going
all these things are taking great
pictures with you
but what happens to them the best photos
never make it off our phones then you
get a new phone and you're like I guess
that pictures gone some of those photos
deserve more than a Facebook post or an
email some photo should be where you can
see them every day
keepsake frames is the easy way to frame
photos from your phone in seconds
whether you're doing some home
decorating or looking for a thoughtful
personal gift right it's easy download
the keepsake frames app upload a photo
and choose a frame every keepsake frame
is handmade in the USA from high-quality
materials they even have canvas options
keepsake frames are shipped direct from
their studio prices start at just 25
bucks and shipping is always free
digital photos to life without time or
cost of going to a frame shop it's way
easier and cheaper you can even see a
detailed preview of the final product
before you buy create custom frame print
right now in under 30 seconds now
through July 4th they're offering an
incredible deal for our listeners 30%
off your first order when you use promo
code Congrats download the keepsake
frames app and get 40% off plus free
shipping when you use promo code
Congrats that's 30% off with the
keepsake frames at promo code Congrats
look left you see that blank wall put a
keepsake frame on it square cache if you
haven't heard we're switching to the
cash app now you have heard cuz you
listened to this episode but if you
haven't you you know you got to get into
you got to get into this episode just
progress a little bit more it's the
number one ranked app in finance and
lets you do the most with your money
cash app whether you want to pay people
back buy and sell Bitcoin deposit your
paycheck right into the app or order a
free custom cash card to spend anywhere
you like the cash cards boost program
lets you get instant discounts every
time you swipe your card right now you
can get $1 off every purchase you make
it coffee shops across the country when
you pay for our cash will you pay when
you pay with your cash card it's got
discounts like 50% off at Chipotle 50%
off at Shake Shack and more they're
rolling out new boosts for the cash card
constantly so follow cash app on
Instagram and Twitter to find out what
boosts are next what boosts are next
it's great you can also do the black
debit card the cash car black debit card
show us your designs buying some Bitcoin
it's awesome and of course when you
download the cash app and enter reward
codes rewards code Congrats
five dollars goes to you and five
dollars goes to time's up Legal Defense
Fund and we support that here at the at
the at our podcast congratulations
download the free cash app for iOS or
Android now we're learning a lot babies
I didn't order food that's fine it's all
good
oh okay we're learning a lot and it's
all good
we [ __ ] didn't order food and we it's
all good [ __ ] knocking through these
ads and we're knocking through these
notes dude I have four notes today for
two word notes that's how much [ __ ]
disrespect I had for you that's how you
show respect disrespect cuz you're being
you the more disrespectful you are the
more respectful you are cuz you're not
putting up these [ __ ] walls for these
[ __ ] you're showing them how
you really are and that being said don't
spit in anyone's face if that's the real
you then guess what you're just a piece
of [ __ ] bu but hopefully you're not
[ __ ] up didn't end then then then
right since secure but yeah I'm hot I'm
hot how about that
I'm hot as [ __ ] hey what's up with 50
cent on Instagram
why you losing your mind bro get this
strap how about that he'll it'll be a
picture of like a [ __ ] chick with a
fat ass damn they don't want me to work
today on Instagram they don't want me
damn social media doesn't want me to
work right they trying to keep me
hornier than a [ __ ] get this
strapped huh laughs it's crazy what what
Instagram and the social media has been
and how it's made us you haven't shown
us how everyone is losing their goddamn
mind dude how about the lady the white
lady that called the [ __ ] black girl
up for selling water look at her [ __ ]
face dude and how she knelt down dude
she tried to get out
that's so [ __ ] she should have just
started being British it would have made
it a lot better for her you know what
you're not supposed to sell water and
then there were oh you're gonna sell
your now you know everybody's gonna know
- and she just goes I'm sorry about no
accounts I won't - in America I don't
understand why this [ __ ] girl is
doing this dude what could be poisoned
she needs a license for it
god what a [ __ ] dummy who the [ __ ]
cares imagine calling the cops on
someone selling water she didn't she
doesn't look as racist as the other lady
though the other one that pretended that
got a look at her face dude look at that
face with the on the meme with her
[ __ ] making that thin-lipped well you
know shouldn't sell water hop dick by
the way that's we know what's worse than
that speeding she [ __ ] definitely
sped in her in her life um yeah I don't
know that's what septa that's the set
that Dallas show was [ __ ] awesome
dude I love you Dallas you're [ __ ]
awesome
you're just cool I [ __ ] loved that
Dallas show we sold out the [ __ ] and
by we I mean me sold out the
the majestic theatre [ __ ] get this
strap dude sold out the majestic theatre
get this strap I started doing this
thing because I got the fire tattoo on
my hand
I started doing this [ __ ] and sold it
out that's my new [ __ ] dude
I make the [ __ ] and I'd do it on
apologetically dude that's the sound of
fire bro
if a girl hits on me if I get some
[ __ ] money
uh-oh
hopefully I'm holding all paper products
in my right hand cuz the left hands got
the fire dude I'm gonna run for governor
dude I'm gonna run for governor and what
I'm gonna do is screenshot every shitty
thing I've ever said and put him on a
shirt and run on those shirts so nobody
can expose me [ __ ] like every time I've
ever liked like like just be like
[ __ ] I went to a strip club
March 30th 1990s well I guess in 2004
I'm gonna wear a shirt that says that so
nobody could be like he went to a strip
club in 2004 on March 30th do we really
want him governing California and I
golike and then and then I by the way I
buy the next commercial spot and I'm on
the and I'm on the next commercial spot
and it's just me with that same shirt on
and I go like this [ __ ] yeah you do and
that's it and it goes beep it beeps it
out cuz everyone's a [ __ ] [ __ ] right
[ __ ] yeah you do and I bye
that [ __ ] DJ Khaled song hey DJ
Khaled show your [ __ ] kid more you
know
hey DJ Khaled you I put on worldstar
worldstar [ __ ] put there was a
picture of DJ Khaled hitting the buttons
on the on the DJ thing and then DJ Kyle
was like oh album alert and I wrote and
I wrote on the underworld star I wrote
oh is this why the last album was so
[ __ ] shitty and everyone's like well
a lot of people were like hi that's
funny you know cuz they get I'm a
comedian but some people were like like
I'm just [ __ ] around by the way I
haven't heard that I'm sure it's [ __ ]
banging I don't know you know I'm just
being I'm just I'm just roasting baby
you know [ __ ] that I'm slamming all you
[ __ ] owe me 12 1250 why because
I [ __ ] I I delivered you an
all-american slam that's it that's it
that's all that happened do it I'm sorry
I'm sorry dude but you owe me 1250 um
and people were like oh
yo bro why you [ __ ] this in that
you're really gonna [ __ ] you ain't you
what about your who are you that's my
favorite who are you like there's
anybody besides like five people in the
world like that's any barometer of
success there's so many people that
don't know so many [ __ ] famous is way
more famous than me I'm barely famous
these [ __ ] there are people who
don't know boo Brad Pitt is dude Justin
Bieber um living you know just Justin
Bieber who else Trump I mean who else my
dad doesn't know who ariana grande is
she's the most famous [ __ ] person so
like this is also my other favorite
thing some guy tweeted me this my
favorite thing I mean I want to jump off
a [ __ ] two-story house he tweets me
this is something that people always
write hey Chris hey Chris Lee I'm coming
to your show in Houston haven't decided
which day yet when can I catch you at
your prime i io I it's like I don't try
harder sometimes I'm always trying to go
do the best I can
how am I supposed to know what do I have
[ __ ] praecox even if I did I wouldn't
be wasting my time on what shows are the
best I'd be out there trying to fight
crime the guy wrote back I wrote back
people always ask me this as if I try
harder to do better during certain shows
and not others it's a silly question I
don't know what shows will be better
because they haven't happened yet and
the guy wrote the guy wrote back anyway
can't wait to see you now I just feel
slammed um nah he's not gonna get
blocked that's not a blog cover like oh
we're gonna block just a silly question
bro how do I know Whitney just tweeted
now Walgreens sucks I don't know how
much more I can take of this what
happened we have Walgreens do you know
Jesus every new every new day Walgreens
he's we're learning something live here
on the podcast which is what we never do
what happened to Walgreens Walgreens
pharmacist denies a woman medication to
end her unviable pregnancy why did that
happen
Oh for personal beliefs
oh Jesus Christ well that's not
Walgreens fault all right that's the
thing it's not Walgreens fault it's some
[ __ ] [ __ ] that works for Walgreens
that's the thing like the Starbucks on
[ __ ] Starbucks it's great it's racist no
it's not that [ __ ] is racist I don't
how they [ __ ] blame these companies
sometimes it's like you know we gotta be
better kidding I don't know we I mean we
obviously have to be better but I know
what the [ __ ] is going on here
look there's a racist in there all right
um
you know it's funny - I do have some
news I could share with you guys but I'm
not kind of how about that for irony
that's when I bring it up the day I have
news not gonna [ __ ] give it to you
how about that how about that chillin
out in my orange chair with my orange
shirt not telling you news because I
don't wanna I was on fighter in the kid
last week and [ __ ] man that was fun
we got the old TMP crew back to back
together will Will Sasso Bryan Callen I
guest-hosted I co-hosted for [ __ ]
Brendan Schaub my boy Brendan was in was
doing something in Houston doing
stand-up and buying all sorts of shoes
wearing his tight pants love him for
that by the way I want to wear more more
tight pants but my legs are the size of
a toothpick and I do leg day so much and
I work so hard I'm trying to get that
teardrop
oh my quadricep above my knee but it's
so hard it's a hard I can't get it my
legs won't grow Brown I wanna
I have I have I have [ __ ] thin legs
now I have a thin body
you know I'm vide out I got a [ __ ]
swimmers body all good look so sue me I
have a [ __ ] swimmers body
my mom used to tell me that when I was
in my teens it's all good did it stick
with me yes do I actually think I have
one no do I say it in a funny way
mockingly yes but um I guess hosted it
brought Brian a [ __ ] serious
strawberry milkshake he can't have it
cause it's psoriasis
it's [ __ ] guys psoriasis fifty-two
years old has psoriasis because he
[ __ ] takes a bunch of supplements
that some guy gives them I put it on my
Instagram you can see it if you want to
um anyway we want to have some Twitter
questions let's go to Twitter questions
babies I talked about the real issues it
sucks how ice melts huh right what's up
with temperature it's all [ __ ] up or
stand-up of all time here we go by
little hey it's Lita okay how do you how
do you one fire and iPhone get rid of
come up with the titles to each episode
obviously they come from within within
each episode after you've recorded but
for example lil monopoly peace and not
man on flyer does this make sense well
you kind of answered your own question
however I will say we we did think man
on flyer but since I already have a
special called man on fire I didn't I
just didn't want someone like for me I
was like I don't want people to mix it
up I want one thing to be one thing and
then not to be able to be [ __ ] I
don't ever want god forbid something is
oh did you mean man on flyer or do you
write man on fire who you write man on
flyer into some and then Google's like
did you mean man how far it was just a
little confusing people are [ __ ]
idiots out there a little monopoly piece
sounds funny and to me if I heard
something low monopoly piece I'd be like
I'll click on that so that's how I came
up with that one but you kind of
answered your own question we just come
up with whatever whatever made us laugh
and a lot of times in the episode I'll
be trying to be doing the thing I'll be
like oh that's the title and then I
forget it and then one fire will be like
what's the title and be like I had one
I don't know all right next question
thanks for that was a good one
would you rather find out when you die
or how you die huh I don't care about
that question how about that match [ __ ]
on [ __ ] on match [ __ ] tone that's your
name huh
all right well people made funny huh um
I don't know I just I don't want to talk
about that [ __ ] weird am Orban got
morbid guy I like how one fire was like
we got to wrap up and we have Twitter
questions so can we get to that and we
didn't we did in half first we had two
questions and we need to wrap up oh oh
now he's the guy who was like well I
said a couple that means - that guy
needs to [ __ ] jump out a plane well
that's a little extreme you need to
[ __ ] like skip lunch I don't want you
to have a lunch one fire that's
ridiculous yeah I got a couple I got a
couple questions really yet and then he
says - oh that's it yeah I said a couple
oh really oh so your foot your [ __ ]
you're a [ __ ] okay cool
it's all good um dude there was a guy in
Landy's get the thing I wanna go to this
guy's Instagram I sent it to somebody I
don't know if I sent it no I didn't send
it you guys cuz you guys any time I said
anything about rap - the check - the
checkroom - the chain - the chain and no
one gives a [ __ ] you do you do actually
one fire does but the rest of them don't
where is it here
this guy a.k.a kil th EMC a killed the
MC with one L cool it says I'm not Tupac
and then he's rapping and he says it's
one thing to say is it's one thing this
is not the most [ __ ] up in Instagram
of the week even though it kinda is so
we're not gonna play the theme song it's
one thing to say someone looks like a
person but another to say they are
that they are that person I met Tupac in
1989 sir bragging for less than a minute
at Malcolm X grassroots building on the
east side of LA we doesn't get specific
we was both connected by way of the
organization n APO he was from the
Oakland chapter visiting the LA chapter
for a naming ceremony before he was
famous
I seen not talked to him two other times
a specific going backtrack Eve mo
becoming back mr. backtrack Eve Moana
bragging in an elevator it's a specific
going to traffic court he was with I
mean Jesus Christ okay going to traffic
where he was with the real spice one
rapper in the [ __ ] eighties and
nineties I never said anything because
they was engaged in a conversation that
was not mines talking about an incident
that happened to him with some Crips I
seen not talked to him again at the
Criminal Court building with Snoop is on
trial I mean Jesus Christ is specific
those are my only encounters with Tupac
all lies on me
he made a music video rapping he people
are saying he's saying people are saying
he's Tupac and looks like Tupac now let
me tell you something you can look it up
I gave you the [ __ ] he doesn't look
anything like Tupac and this is the song
[Music]
no gang size that got principal size so
I don't take sides yes you play in the
field the politician as far as I'm
concerned
oh my god it's so weird
imagine being somebody that like imagine
like if I was like dude people think I'm
Josh Duhamel you would be like oh well
no they don't but I I think that I think
people are set saying I am Josh Duhamel
you know they did they always they come
up dude I'm not Josh - mouth dude I'm
not the guy from Transformers people
come up to me they say oh I love you in
transformers dude I'm not that guy I met
him once at [ __ ] traffic court and
I've seen him I did not talk to him but
at the DMV I was in line and I saw him
waiting not in I did not say I saw him
also again in [ __ ] 2007 at the park
in Oxnard I was walking my dog I used to
live over there and I saw him I did not
say I saw him I know he's someone else I
am NOT him there are no mirrors in parks
I was not looking in a mirror just stop
calling and thinking I'm Josh Adil Mao
or Duhamel whatever the word [ __ ] hey
saying alright babies we wrap it up
Ottawa Ontario London Ontario Buffalo
Burlington Philadelphia follow the
leader tour let's do this Washington DC
Portland Maine Portland Maine Maine next
week Hampton Beach Mashantucket
Connecticut Houston texted Texas coming
up Wichita Kansas Kansas City MO and a
bunch of others go to follow the leader
go to Chris D'Elia calm and check out my
tour dates tour dates blue apron
remember to check out this week's menu
and get your first three meals free at
blue apron calm / congrats to get your
first 3 meals free do that square cash
get check out the new boost rewards
program get the cash app and to reward
coach Congrats I always say reward code
and to rewards code Congrats get $5 gift
$5 - times up get it for iOS or Android
now and there is new [ __ ] in the store
finally and that's how he wrote it new
[ __ ] in the store finally one fire
I haven't get rid of new merch is what
we mean is it disrespectful but in
actuality what do we learn today that's
the new respectful so go to Crystal
Viacom get the new merch and go to the
follow leader tour we're getting new
shirts up there for follow the leader
subscribe to the YouTube channel that
comes out every Tuesday or Wednesday the
video is very cool download the Chris
D'Elia app for iOS or Android now and
you can see the podcast before anyone
else if you're a subscriber watch my
specials and here's a call to action
have everybody everyone tell your friend
for watch man on fire that'll be cool
just to give him a little briefing in
the cult all right we'll see at his show
babies remember all lies on me
[Music]